When do we get a cooking stream with Kohai?
Um, to be honest, I'm a little clumsy.
Last time I tried to go in the kitchen,
mama said, get out.
Yeah, I mean, I don't blame her.
You want to hear a funny story?
So I was trying to cut strawberries with a fruit knife.
And if you didn't know, fruit knives,
the sharp part is not the curved part.
The sharp part is the flat side.
You can see where I'm getting at, right?
So I was cutting strawberries,
and I was having trouble cutting the strawberries.
And mama looked at me and said, it's upside down.
And you know what I did?
I flipped the strawberry and not the knife.
And continued trying to,
to,
continued trying to cut it.
I got it in the end when she grabbed the knife
and put it down to the flat side instead.
How did you survive this long?
I have no idea, to be honest.